STEPHANIE WONG: I'm Stephanie
Wong from the Google
campus in Sunnyvale.
And we're talking baseball.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Today, we're trying
to figure out
what makes players popular with
fans in Major League Baseball
and how you can use machine
learning to predict it.
And joining me, MJ
Jacob, Cloud Engineer.
MJ JACOB: From New York City.
STEPHANIE WONG: And
Dale Markowitz, applied
AI engineer here at Google.
Hey guys, good stuff.
OK, so first of all, are you
both baseball fans at all?
DALE MARKOWITZ:
I'm a baseball fan,
but I'm really a data nerd.
So I think being a
data nerd makes you
kind of be a baseball
fan because there's just
so much to analyze.
It's like being
in a candy store.
What about you, MJ?
MJ JACOB: Yeah, I
would say I have
a pretty healthy relationship
with baseball for two reasons.
Number one, when I
was a kid growing up,
I used to play a home
run derby all the time.
And nothing's like just knocking
some pitches out of the park.
And number two, I love going
to in-person baseball games,
like, being able
to eat a hot dog
with your drink with your
friends, your sunglasses on,
it's a beautiful show.
STEPHANIE WONG: So
let's get to our lineup.
We have some amazing
guests today.
We have Josh Frost, vice
president of Product
at Major League Baseball.
MJ JACOB: And Kevin Youkilis,
a three-time MLB All-Star.
A player who was incredibly
popular for reasons
that weren't obvious unless
you were a dating nerd.
[DRUMS]
STEPHANIE WONG: All right, so
you guys, what do you think
are the types of data sets
that would help determine
a really popular player online?
MJ JACOB: Number one, I'd love
to collect data from TikTok.
Lots of trends coming
out a TikTok, of course.
Number two, the
most popular songs
that are currently trending.
And then number three,
the most popular dances.
And the reason for this is
think about back in the day
when John Wall was
trending, right?
Everyone was like, do the
John Wall-- do the John Wall.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
It was crazy because while
he was an awesome basketball
player, I think a lot
more people knew him.
And he was a lot more
popular because of that dance
and that song that came out.
Dale, what about you?
Can you fill the rest of the--
DALE MARKOWITZ: I went on
social media with TikTok stuff
that you want too.
But I also want some
more boring things,
like maybe how is
popularity measured?
And like, what sort of users are
more likely to submit answers,
like what is their ages?
What device types?
So all of the unsexy stuff
that actually can make
a big difference in the end.
What do you think, Stephanie?
STEPHANIE WONG: Yeah,
I think there are
a couple in between things--
more fun and boring, I guess.
It's TikTok dances
because, obviously, those
are a big driver for
what's trending these days.
Or does a player have
a orange or red beard
like Justin Turner?
So there are ton of things
that you can look at and even
social justice issues, like
if they've been really active
about those things in the past.
MJ JACOB: Yeah, and I think
that's super important,
that last point you
just touched on,
Steph, because at
the end of the day,
I love whe players
can use their platform
to make a difference
in the world.
And when they become
popular because of that,
I think that's an incredible--
two birds, one stone.
STEPHANIE WONG: Hard to
put that into a column,
but it would be neat.
Joining us now is Josh
Frost with a little bit more
about how to define an
all-star baseball player
and to talk about an exciting
challenge for data scientists
who love the game.
JOSH FROST: Hey, how's it going?
STEPHANIE WONG: OK,
so Josh, we know
that there is an exciting new
Kaggle competition and MLB.
Can you tell us a little bit
more about the details of it?
JOSH FROST: Yeah, it's
a really exciting one
because it's pretty
different, we
feel, from what's been done
before in the Kaggle space
and certainly in our world.
Effectively, we're
trying to ask AI and ML
enthusiasts to try and predict
what makes a popular player.
So digital engagement is
really how we measure that.
And we're giving
pretty rich data sets
to challenge people to say,
can you divine some signal?
Can you create an algorithm to
help predict player popularity?
And we have really
rich data sets
there, lots of documentation
on what the information is.
But ultimately, we think it's
a really unique opportunity
for you to try your
skill sets at making
a prediction at a
business problem
that we think about
every day and that lots
of sports and media
companies alike are thinking
about every day as well.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
- Wow.
MJ JACOB: All right,
so Josh, I got to know.
What makes an all-star
player in your opinion?
So I think the question
that's really interesting
is what makes someone
beloved by the fans,
not just for what you do on
the field that's very creative.
But staying after,
sign autograph,
creating a cool video,
collabing with local artists.
All those things are
really strong signals
that help define the
modern all-stars.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
DALE MARKOWITZ: So Josh,
talking about players
that they'd love it,
I got to tell you.
So I'm an applied AI
engineer here at Google.
And I'm like a big fan girl
actually for what you do.
And what the MLB
does with data, I
mean, we're going to enter
into this Kaggle competition,
like, what sort of data are
we going to have to work with?
JOSH FROST: Yeah, we think it's
really unique because it's not
just an entertainment product.
It's a performance
product as well.
It's really a
business, of course.
You're getting these
really unique data sets
combining the differences
between on-field performance,
the business metrics of how fans
interact in the digital space,
both on our core platforms
and even on social as well.
So you'll get some pretty
distinct data sets there.
And then what we
call our stats API
says this huge
range of information
that allows you to marry it up
with something that you really
want to think about.
So something that we've
found a lot of interest
in looking at
already is when you
see spikes for someone on
either the player page views
or under social
[INAUDIBLE] like,
did that correlate with anything
that happened on the field?
DALE MARKOWITZ:
Is there anything
that you've learned using
all this now combined
data that was very surprising
that you didn't expect?
JOSH FROST: Yeah,
I think I'm always
surprised and impressed
how nationality
and, like country of origin can
be a really strong influence.
So when Shohei
Ohtani plays, there's
going to be strong correlations
really throughout Asia.
But there are also other, like
less well-known correlations
on when this player comes
and plays at the stadium,
he overindexes.
Why?
Maybe he's from that town.
Maybe he's from that area or
played college ball there.
STEPHANIE WONG: So being
from San Francisco myself,
I totally agree that an
origin is a huge part
of the whole equation for me.
But who would you
vote for in this case?
JOSH FROST: Well,
I'm super biased.
I'm from Chicago
or outside Chicago.
So I'm always going
to vote for the Cubs.
But this year, I think I
have a pretty good case.
Recently, Javy Báez had
this incredible play.
He's called "El Mago" which
means a magician in Spanish.
And he can literally create
something out of nothing.
And he is a top performer.
So I'll definitely
be voting for him.
But he's also a top
performer because he's
so dynamic and having swag--
impossible to define but also
definitely noticeable as well.
MJ JACOB: Or could
popularity be based off
the shoes or the bling
that they're wearing.
JOSH FROST: We
were joking that I
would love to create a
metric for the swag chain
that Fernando Tatis Jr. wears
that like, every time he
makes this mind-blowing
grand slam,
he's putting this very cool,
hilarious, big gold chain on,
like, no data can measure that.
But like, plenty of data
could measure how people
react and feel about it, right?
DALE MARKOWITZ: As we learn
about the more subtle things
that make players
really valuable,
are fans understanding that?
Are they understanding
when a player is valuable
even if it's not in a Swagway?
JOSH FROST: Yeah, that's what I
love about this era of baseball
is that there's never been a
deeper appreciation from a fan
or a front office perspective
for on-field performance,
right?
So it's really fun and
exciting to talk about swag
and all those other topics.
Yeah, I've always believed that
all players have a data story
mostly because that helps track
the way that they've evolved
from someone who was
playing little league all
the way to being a
major leaguer, right?
And the data story can be in
how a scout discovered them.
It could be an
anomaly or a pattern.
Kevin Youkilis is a famous
example, commonly referred
to as the Greek
God of Walks where
he was noticed because he
was excellent at getting
on base through walks.
- Ball four.
JOSH FROST: Something
else that you've
seen in the last
couple of seasons
is that we're using not just
data, but video as well.
We have consumer
data, on field data.
We have business data
and industry data.
Now, machine learning at AI is
giving us these opportunities
to start gleaning
insights across all
of these different data sets.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
STEPHANIE WONG: Thank you so
much for joining us today.
And we hope that we get
to see you on the field
out there someday.
JOSH FROST: Yeah, can't wait.
STEPHANIE WONG: Do
you think you can have
an impact on America's pastime?
Maybe you can.
Join the MLB Player Digital
Engagement Forecasting
Competition.
The competition will dive
deeper into the player
fandom of America's pastime.
MJ JACOB: The result--
the ability to predict the
most popular players for MLB.
And yo, you can win
$50,000 in prize money.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
STEPHANIE WONG: So Josh
mentioned three-time MLB
All-Star player Kevin Youkilis.
And we just happen to
have Kevin Youkilis
here on the show with us today.
Kevin, Youk.
MJ JACOB: Youk.
Let's get it.
[LAUGHS]
KEVIN YOUKILIS: Good morning.
DALE MARKOWITZ: [LAUGHS]
STEPHANIE WONG: Morning.
Thank you so much
for being here.
I have to ask first
off, what is it
like being known as
the Greek God of Walks?
MJ JACOB: And do you think
that's why you were so popular?
KEVIN YOUKILIS: Oh,
the Greek God of Walks.
Well, this is something
that's been a part of my life
since I was in, wow, AA
baseball around 2003.
I got dubbed this by
the book, "Moneyball."
And it's funny
because I'm not Greek.
But of Romanian
descent of my father's
side with the Youkilis name.
So it was a name change.
But the Greek community
still loves me to this day.
So and I love the Greek
culture and love the food.
So I still consider
myself Greek in some ways.
Yeah, it was one of those
times where it's wild.
They got a lot of recognition
in the minor leagues.
I never had recognition
ever in my life--
a little bit here and there.
But I was an underdog.
DALE MARKOWITZ: So do
you think that life
would have been different
if you were there
before big data became
a real big thing?
KEVIN YOUKILIS:
It's funny, like,
so when analytics started
coming about in the early years,
a lot of it was back
behind the scenes.
As baseball players, we just
went out there every day.
We practiced.
We worked hard.
So analytics became a
big deal probably, yeah,
right around the time
when I got drafted.
It started to become more
of the norm of learning
about on-base
percentage understanding
that the key to baseball
is getting on base.
On-base percentage is also
a part of getting hits.
So average was a big
deal for a long time.
But on-base percentage
included walks, hit by pitches.
And it became a focal point.
The data and analytics is
really good for the coaching.
There's a lot of
good information
that is quick and easy,
whereas before, you'd
have to have different
video angles of the hitters,
trying to assess and see
what kind of body movements
they have.
Now, we have the ability to
assess those body movements.
So when a player is in a funk
or doing something, maybe
there's something little
that we can take out of it.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
MJ JACOB: So Kevin, on
that point, I'm curious.
When you watch the video
and you assess the data,
how frequent is it
that the data actually
is accurate with what
you're seeing in the video?
KEVIN YOUKILIS: We talk
about this all the time is
players make the analytics.
And then the analytics
are evaluated
by other people that are
very smart and intelligent
and understand how
to break it down.
So that's one of the
funny parts about it.
And the video doesn't
lie a lot of times.
DALE MARKOWITZ: I'm
sure some players must
be more connected with
the data than others.
They have like a data head.
KEVIN YOUKILIS: Yes, there
are some players that
are very, very into the data.
There's other players
that don't want any data.
There's a lot of analytics, like
driven into the pitching side
because you're
really on offense.
You're in control of
throwing the ball.
It's like golf.
The ball's sitting right there.
And that's why it's become
super big, analytic-driven,
because you control
what you're doing.
As a hitter, you're
actually on defense.
You're reacting to
what they're doing.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
- Strike one.
MJ JACOB: Now, you're a rookie
on the Boston Red Sox when
y'all vanquished the
Curse of the Bambino.
Do you really think data had
anything to do with that?
KEVIN YOUKILIS: Front
office used data
to get the team, right?
So you plug and play players.
I mean, Theo Epstein has done
a great job of that of years
is building a lineup
and trying to figure out
what kind of players you want.
And I think he did
that in a lot of ways.
He saw value in certain players.
And yeah, so like,
we got a David Ortiz
for the Minnesota Twins that
he was a Major League player.
But they just didn't
see him because they
had other players that they
thought were more valuable.
MJ JACOB: Wow, so the data
helped get the players
on the team.
But once the players
were on the team,
that's where the
full human kicked in.
And let's feel.
Let's practice.
Let's get better day by day.
No data apart of that.
KEVIN YOUKILIS: Once you
get to a certain level,
pretty much everyone's
on a playing field.
Some are greater athletes
than others physically.
But it's the mind and
how you slow down.
And there's not a lot
of analytics for that.
A good coach understands
the player and how they
can handle certain analytics.
And if you understand
the player first,
then you can
introduce the things
slowly into the
player's mind in order
to make them better every day.
STEPHANIE WONG:
Thank you so much
for your time today, Kevin.
KEVIN YOUKILIS: Thank you.
Yeah, we're excited.
Go Sox.
STEPHANIE WONG: Go Sox.
Youk.
MJ JACOB: Youk.
STEPHANIE WONG: Kevin Youk.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
So now let's talk about the
Kaggle challenge with Major
League Baseball.
It's the MLB Player Digital
Engagement Forecasting
Competition.
The competition will dive
deeper into the player
fandom of America's pastime.
MJ JACOB: Don't forget.
There are $50,000 in
prizes and, of course,
serious bragging
rights up for grabs.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
STEPHANIE WONG: Hope you're
feeling inspired at home.
Remember, you can try Vertex
AI for free in the Google Cloud
console and visit the
companion assets to build
what you've said here today.
That's all for today.
Thanks, everyone.
Bye, Dale.
Bye, MJ.
DALE MARKOWITZ: See ya, Steph.
MJ JACOB: Peace from NYC.
STEPHANIE WONG: Youk.
DALE MARKOWITZ: Youk.